trügerische entwicklung die korona
zahlen fallen aber die experten warnen
die mutationen machen das virus
gefährlicher
kehrtwende in washington us-präsident
beiden legt die außenpolitik seines
vorgängers zu den akten und setzt auf
bündnisse und vorbereitung auf das
winterchaos der nordhälfte deutschlands
drohen ab morgen ein heftiger
schneesturm und eisige kälte
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg herzlich willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem februar
freitag den sport in der sendung
präsentiert norbert lehmann
ein schwimmender familie es wird wohl
nichts mit einer baldigen lockerung der
korona beschränkungen zu groß ist die
angst vor den noch ansteckenden virus
varianten das mühsam erreichte dürfe
nicht leichtfertig verspielt werden sagt
der gesundheitsminister
immerhin nach fast zwei monaten harte
einschränkungen sinken die
infektionszahlen weiter das robert koch
institut meldet heute 12 1908
neuinfektionen 855 menschen sind in
verbindung mit dem virus gestorben
die sieben tage incidents sinkt weiter
und liegt knapp unter 80
ein blick auf die deutschlandkarte zeigt
immer mehr städte und landkreise werden
gelb oder zumindest orange rutschen also
unter die inzidenz von 50 aus berlin
weniger jens spahn schickt eins vorweg
diese pandemie ist für ihn wie für alle
anderen eine probe auch fürs eigene
nervenkostüm und ja auch ich bin diese
pandemie leid
auch ich will wie alle anderen so
schnell wie möglich zurück zur
normalität
zur freiheit zur gewohnten
unbefangenheit spielraum für lockerungen
sieht der gesundheitsminister derzeit
kaum obwohl die infektionszahlen sinken
erstmalig seit dem 24 oktober sind wir
wieder unter der 80er instanz diese
ermutigende entwicklung haben wir uns
als gesellschaft durch konsequenz und
auch durch viel verzicht erarbeitet
deshalb sollten wir das so mühsam
erreichte nun nicht leichtfertig
verspielen
das problem dass politik und
wissenschaft derzeit sehen dass corona
virus verändert sich erste daten über
mutationen in deutschland sind im januar
erhoben worden
aber noch fehlt ein gesamtüberblick das
macht die einschätzung weil die
verbreitung der mutationen schwierig sie
dominieren das geschehen noch nicht aber
wir müssen damit rechnen dass sich der
anteil weiter erhöht ähnlich wie es auch
in anderen europäischen ländern
berichtet wurde in den letzten wochen
auch die frage wie gut die impfstoffe
gegen mutationen wirken kann die
wissenschaft noch nicht endgültig
beantworten
deshalb bleibe nur ein weg insofern ist
es wichtig dass sie jetzt mit den
vorhandenen lebens stoffel auch zügig
weiter impfen denn das hilft vielleicht
partiell aber auf jeden fall auch gegen
neue parierenden wie geht's weiter
nächsten mittwoch wollen bund und länder
hier wieder beraten
insgesamt sei das virus gefährlicher
geworden sagt der chef des robert koch
instituts zwar dominieren die korona
varianten in deutschland noch nicht das
infektionsgeschehen aber man müsse damit
rechnen dass sie sich weiter ausbreiten
als schipanski hat details sie macht die
größte sorge die mutanten b 11 7
sie ist deutlich ansteckender und wer
sie hat droht schwerer zu erkranken
in 13 bundesländern wurde sie bereits
nachgewiesen die meisten fälle meldet
schleswig-holstein 47 gefolgt von
nordrhein westfalen und berlin
das virus ist noch nicht müde im
gegenteil es hat gerade doch wer einen
boost bekommen und deshalb müssen wir
unbedingt dran bleiben knapp sechs
prozent der neuinfektionen entfallen
momentan auf diese mutation wie schnell
das meer wird zeigen länder wie dänemark
von 0,3 prozent stieg es zunächst
langsam auf 7,3 dann aber innerhalb
einer woche schon auf 13 prozent der
neuinfektionen inzwischen fast 20 in
portugal war die lage lange zeit nicht
kritisch und dann kam die mutation nun
ist es das eu land mit den derzeit
höchsten corona zahlen die mutations
quote liegt bereits bei rund 60 prozent
dramatisch abzulesen auch an den
gestiegenen todeszahlen darum ist es so
wichtig dass auch wenn lockungen
durchgeführt werden zum beispiel kitas
oder schulen
was immer entschieden wird aber es muss
mit konzepten geöffnet werden bis
impfstoffe flächendeckend helfen vergeht
noch wertvolle zeit und die mutante b 11
7 hat es eilig die panini und die
impfstoffe da lief nicht alles rund
nur in deutschland auch die impfstoff
beschaffung der eu wird heftig
kritisiert und das zu recht räumte jetzt
kommissionspräsidentin ursula von der
leyen ein der süddeutschen zeitung sagte
sie die eu habe sich sehr stark auf die
entwicklung der impfstoffe konzentriert
zitat rückblickend hätten wir stärker
parallel über die herausforderungen der
massenproduktion nachdenken müssen
zu denken geben muss der europäischen
union auch der streit mit russland über
den kreml-kritiker alexej nawalny bis
heute eskaliert zum ersten mal seit
jahren besucht ein eu chefdiplomat
moskau der außenbeauftragte joseph [ __ ]
l und währenddessen weiß der kreml
mehrere eu diplomaten aus auch einen
deutschen der vorwurf sie hätten an
kundgebungen der opposition teilgenommen
die bundesregierung regierung kritisiert
die ausweisung scharf und droht mit
konsequenzen christiansen berichtet dass
das kein freundschaftsbesuch wird war
schon vor dem treffen klar von
fundamentalen differenzen und mangelndem
vertrauen spricht josef pröll bei seinem
besuch in moskau vor allem ein thema
vergiftet das verhältnis der fall
alexei navalny mein besuch fällt
zusammen mit der verhaftung und
verurteilung von alexei navalny und den
festnahmen tausender demonstranten
wie erwartet habe ich minister lawrow
auf unsere tiefe besorgnis mitgeteilt
und unseren appell für seine freilassung
unter einleitung einer untersuchung
seiner vergiftung
russland hatte schon vor dem treffen
betont man sei bereit über alles zu
sprechen aber nicht sich zu neuwahlen
die ratschläge anzuhören und mögliche
neue eu sanktionen sagt sergey lavrov
wir haben uns daran gewöhnt dass die eu
immer häufiger einseitiger restriktionen
anwendet die keine legitime grundlage
haben und wir gestalten unser leben
davon ausgehen dass die eu ein
unzuverlässiger partner ist
währenddessen steht alexej nawalny
erneut vor gericht drei tage nach seiner
verurteilung zu zwei jahren und acht
monaten straflager musste er sich heute
wegen verleumdung verantworten
nach dem treffen zwischen borel und
lavrov teilt russland mit man werde drei
eu diplomaten ausweisen weil sie an den
illegalen demonstrationen für navalny
teilgenommen hätten scharfe kritik aus
berlin
wir halten diese ausweisung für
ungerechtfertigt und glauben dass das
eine weitere facette in dem es was
ziemlich fern ab von rechtsstaatlichkeit
im augenblick gerade in russland zu
beobachten ist eigentlich sprach die
kanzlerin heute mit emanuel makro über
gemeinsamen verteidigungsprojektes dann
die nachricht aus moskau
und obwohl beide die ausweisung der
diplomaten verurteilen scheint
ausgerechnet heute der widerstand
frankreichs gegen die deutsch russische
gaspipeline nord stream zwei zu brechen
ich habe das thema in frage gestellt wir
haben uns abgesprochen eine entscheidung
wurde getroffen jetzt bin ich absolut
solidarisch am abend wurde in berlin
noch der russische botschafter
einbestellt das immer schlechter
werdende verhältnis zwischen russland
und europa hat heute weitere kapitel
dazu bekommen
da fragen wir nach in brüssel bei anne
gellinek das ist ein ziemlicher affront
gegen die eu was wir heute in russland
passiert ist
ja das kann man wohl so sagen der eu
außenbeauftragte josef borel wollte ja
mit ausgestreckter hand nach moskau
reisen der wollte ausloten auf welchen
internationalen politik feldern man
trotz der meinungsverschiedenheiten
weiter zusammenarbeiten könnte diese
strategie die im übrigen in der eu auch
nicht ganz unumstritten war ist heute
krachend gescheitert die eu
außenminister hatten bei ihrem letzten
treffen sanktionen noch einmal vertagt
man heute das urteil gegen navalny
abwarten und eben auch diesen diese
reise bis nach moskau
jetzt ist wohl der weg zu neuen
sanktionen vorgezeichnet unausweichlich
es wird wohl weitere einreisesperren
geben und das einfrieren von konten von
menschen die für die verhaftung und für
die verurteilten von derweil nicht
zuständig sind
dieser neue diese neue verschärfung des
konflikts zwischen der eu und russland
wird natürlich auch die diskussion über
die pipeline nord stream noch einmal
aufflammen lassen hier sieht sich die eu
allerdings nicht am zuge ein baustopp
könnte wohl nur die deutsche
bundesregierung verfügen die
einschätzung von anne gellinek vielen
dank nach brüssel ein ganz anderer ton
in richtung eu kommt aus den usa
man werde wieder ein enger partner das
betonte präsident biden in seiner ersten
grundsatzrede zur außenpolitik biden
versprach eine abkehr vom
protektionismus bündnisse und
internationale zusammenarbeit sind ihm
wichtig aber auch eine deutlich härtere
haltung gegenüber russland aus
washington
kompanie seine erste außenpolitische
rede beginnt joe biden mit einem
versprechen
amerika ist zurück die diplomatie ist
zurück
damit will der präsident nicht nur
vertrauen bei partnern zurückgewinnen
sondern auch wieder eine stärkere
führungsrolle in der weltpolitik
übernehmen mit klaren worten in richtung
russland
ich habe es präsident putin sehr klar
gemacht anders als mein vorgänger die
tage sind vorbei an denen die usa
wegschauen bei russlands aggressionen
beim eingriff in unsere wahlen
cyberattacken und bei der vergiftung
seiner bürger
wie die eu kritisiert auch beiden den
umgang mit alexei navalny seine
forderung den oppositionellen
freizulassen verurteilte moskau als
aggressive rhetorik beiden hauptgegner
sind also klar russland ist er eine
china der andere für die usa die größte
bedrohung für die demokratie
andererseits hofft auch die regierung
beiden es auf gute geschäfte mit den
chinesen den europäern reicht der
präsident wieder die hand deutschland
zählt er zu den engsten freunden die
amerikanischen allianzen sind unser
größtes kapital diplomatisch zu führen
heißt wieder schulter an schulter mit
unseren verbündeten und unseren
wichtigsten partnern zu stehen
dazu gehört auch dass der abzug von us
truppen aus deutschland vorerst gestoppt
wird
aber wie donald trump ist auch beiden
gegen die deutsch russische pipeline
nord stream 2 und wii trump wird er über
die ausgaben der europäer für die
verteidigung sprechen die internationale
politik wird mit beiden also durchaus
anders aber nicht unbedingt einfacher
zurück nach deutschland dieses jahr ist
ein superwahljahr mit bundestagswahl und
sechs landtagswahlen die ersten beiden
am 14 märz in rheinland pfalz und baden
württemberg was sich dort im moment
abzeichnet zeigt unser politbarometer
extra
wenn schon am nächsten sonntag
landtagswahl in baden württemberg wäre
kämen die grünen von ministerpräsident
kretschmann auf 34 prozent
der koalitionspartner cdu auf 28 afd 11
spd 10 fdp 9 die linke 3 prozent als
ministerpräsident oder präsidentin
wünscht sich eine deutliche mehrheit
winfried kretschmann sogar bei cdu
anhänger innen ist der grüne beliebter
als die cdu-spitzenkandidatin susanne
eisenmann in rheinland-pfalz käme die
spd von ministerpräsidentin malu dreyer
auf 31 prozent die cdu auf 33 afd 7 fdp
5 grüne 13 die linke 4 prozent damit
hätte die jetzige regierung aus spd fdp
und grünen weiterhin eine mehrheit
möglich wäre aber auch eine große
koalition
oder ein schwarz grünes bündnis alle
zahlen und daten aus dem politbarometer
extra finden sie bei uns im netz auf zdf
heute und in unserer app wir schauen
noch mal genauer in die zwei
bundesländer morgen nach rheinland pfalz
heute nach baden württemberg
als größtes problem sehen die menschen
dort erstens die korona krise und
zweitens die umwelt und energiewende
was in baden württemberg besondere
bedeutung hat schließlich hängen dort
fast 500.000 arbeitsplätze am auto über
die herausforderungen des wandels
berichtet rennplatz stolz ist man in
baden württemberg darauf dass carl benz
hier einst das moderne auto erfunden hat
stolz sind seit jeher auch die idee beim
daimler porsche oder einem der zig
autozulieferer arbeiten
doch zunehmend wächst auch die sorge
darüber wie das weitergeht mit der
schlüsselindustrie im land die gefahr
besteht nach wie vor dass wir uns selbst
abhängen das heißt wir müssen wesentlich
dynamischer sein als in der
vergangenheit und nicht hinterher
doppelt sondern wir müssen ganz einfach
sehen dass wir wieder vorsprünge uns
erkämpfen der strukturwandel als risiko
alternative antriebe autonomes und
vernetztes fahren viele auch neue
konkurrenten
bei elringklinger haben sich schon vor
jahren begonnen nicht nur teile für
verbrenner zu bauen
gerade kleinere zulieferer tun sich
damit oft schwerer sagt stefan wolf chef
hier und gleichzeitig gesamtmetall
präsident
ich arbeite immer mit einem bild das ist
ein zug der fährt und der zug der fährt
schon sehr schnell und es wird
unternehmen geben die auf diesen zug
nicht mehr aufspringen können also wir
werden eine konsolidierung sehen unsere
industrie wir wären arbeitsplätze
verlieren bei daimler geht es schon
jetzt wohl um 15 bis 20.000 stellen
weltweit bei mahle sind es fast so viele
am bosch standort schwäbisch gmünd soll
jeder dritte arbeitsplatz wegfallen
alternativen dringend gesucht und sagen
wie kann man beschäftigt auch außerhalb
der branche möglicherweise noch für ganz
andere aufgaben qualifizieren
über die wichtigkeit der
schlüsselindustrie sind sich auch alle
politischen akteure einig jetzt im
wahlkampf sie in die neue zeit zu
bekommen eine schlüsselaufgabe
ein denkwürdiges ereignis mit
seltenheitswert so bezeichnen
meteorologen das was uns möglicherweise
am wochenende erwartet ein wetter im
extremen ganz im süden frühlingshafter
fühlen mit temperaturen bis 20 grad im
norden und in der mitte schneestürme
dauerfrost und stundenlange eisregen wo
besondere vorsicht geboten ist zeigt an
seinem stamm aufrüsten fürs wochenende
beim technischen hilfswerk in achim in
niedersachsen werden die schneeketten
aufgezogen
denn das was da kommt wird wohl extrem
ab morgen mittag etwa dauerschneefall
über der gesamten mitte deutschlands bis
zu 50 zentimeter schnee erwarten die
experten dazu bläst ein eisiger ostwind
es drohen also schneeverwehungen und
südlich dieses schnee bandes gibt es
gefährlichen eisregen es kann also
eispanzer geben zb an den stromleitungen
es drohen stromausfälle
es drohen einige probleme schneeglätte
eis und eisregen ein gefährliches wetter
wochenende
wer irgend kann sollte also am
samstagmittag bis sonntagabend in der
mitte deutschlands möglichst nicht vor
die tür gehen vor den türen in
deutschland sieht es wettermäßig schon
sehr lange sehr unterschiedlich aus im
norden weiß und kalt im süden dagegen
nass und warm beispiel der alpenrand
frühlingstemperaturen mehr als 15 grad
sind drin wo sich diese wetter
gegensätze treffen in der mitte des
landes wird es jetzt dabei erst einmal
so richtig ungemütlich da heißt es dann
bei vielen helfern aufrüsten fürs
winterwochenende jetzt zum sport norbert
da freut sich das deutsche tennis-team
über den einzug ins halbfinale
durch einen hart erkämpften sieg im fa
cup gegen serbien der weltranglisten
erste novak djokovic hatte zunächst
alexander zverev knapp geschlagen er ist
ein teamkollege jan lennard struff
gewannen dagegen sein einzel
die entscheidung dann im doppel
die unbändige freude war alexander
zverev und die an der natruper anzusehen
nachdem sie das hart umkämpft der
entscheidende doppel gegen serbien
gewonnen hatten
da das gesetzte deutsche duo krawietz
verletzungsbedingt passen musste waren
die beiden einzelspieler zu überstunden
auf dem centre court gezwungen
doch war ihnen diese mehrbelastung gegen
djokovic und katsch zu keiner zeit
anzumerken und so konnten sie gleich
ihren ersten matchball zum 2 2 1 nach
sätzen verwandeln
aus der not so überzeugend eine tugend
zu machen dürfte auch im halbfinale
morgen gegen sehr starke russin vonnöten
sein
nachdem der fc liverpool wegen koma
nicht nach leipzig zum champions league
achtelfinal hinspiel am 16 februar
einreisen darf sucht rp nach einer
option denkbar die verlegung der partie
in ein anderes land mit anderen
einreisebestimmungen trainer nagelsmann
optimistisch ich gehe auch davon aus das
hoffe ich auch dass das spiel nicht
ausfällt und dann entschieden wo wir
spielen ob zu hause oder nicht und dann
wenn wir uns gut darauf vorbereiten und
das beste aus der situation machen
ja und auch champions league ist
gladbach ist betroffen und überlegt
ebenfalls eine verlegung des heimspiels
gegen manchester city am 24 februar von
dänemark ist da die rede zum wintersport
und zur bob wm in altenberg dagegen die
deutschen frauen im zweier nach den
ersten beiden von vier läufen auf
medaillenkurs
hinter der titelverteidigerin aus den
usa sie ist die erste verfolgerin auf
die führende amtierende weltmeisterin
kelly humphries usa die vorjahres zweite
kim kulig liegt mit anschieberin
ann-christin strack nach zwei nicht ganz
perfekten läufen und 34
hundertstelsekunden rückstand auf rang
zwei
dazu müssen wir noch den bob ordentlich
für den zweiten tag vorbereiten die
kufen und dann noch mal vollgas auf
jeden fall die beste startzeit auf der
1413 meter langen bahn hatte in beiden
läufen junioren weltmeisterin laura
nolte
sie ist mit 43 hundertstel sekunden
rückstand dritte olympiasiegerin maria
janka liegt bei der heim-wm mehr als
eine sekunde zurück auf rang sieben und
die entscheidung bei den frauen und
überhaupt jede menge wintersport morgen
zdf schon ab 9 uhr gibt es doch etwas zu
tun gut angesichts von schnee und
eisregen ist es ja ohnehin ratsam zu
hause zu bleiben
details zum wetter hat gleich erst
intern christian sievers erwartet sie um
10 im heute journal das gesamte heute
team dankt ihnen für ihr interesse und
wünscht ein schönes wochenende
was machen wenn sie nun auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein schöner abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter eine extreme
wetterlage kündigt sich zum wochenende
an
mit großen schneemengen von morgen abend
bis sonntag um 50 zentimeter von
nordrhein westfalen über niedersachsen
bis sachsen kommen diese großen
schneemengen punktuell zusammen aber
generell ist das eben sehr viel schnee
der auch noch verweht wird mit dem wind
aus ost und zwar ist der auch noch
stürmisch etwas südlicher davon bonn
nordrhein westfalen über hessen bis nach
sachsen ist eisregen dabei spiegelglatte
straßen inklusive man darf diese
wetterlage nicht unterschätzen es ist
sogar lebensgefährlich schauen wir mal
in die nacht da gibt's nach norden viele
wolken mit schnee bei temperaturen von
minus fünf bis sieben grad im südwesten
und hier kommt regen auf morgen im
tagesverlauf gibt es weiteren regen der
allmählich gefriert hierüber der mitte
teilweise eben spiegelglatte straßen ab
den abendstunden und sonst schneefälle
die sich in der nacht auf sonntag vor
allem immer weiter intensivieren
ja und das bei temperaturen von minus
zwei grad im nordosten und 15 grad an
den alpen hier mit unterstützung von
fünf ja- und am sonntag gibt es kräftige
schneefälle wie gesagt bis 50 zentimeter
ist möglich dazu sturm aus ost ja und
das bei 10 grad im südwesten sehr mild
und minus acht grad im osten und die
nächsten tage sehr kalt über schnee bis
minus zehn grad und am montag noch
schneefall ein schöner ab